qué significó para ambos países y para
la región que se cortará el comercio
entre colombia y venezuela durante estos
siete años
bueno afectó de manera muy importante
ambos países venezuela y colombia tenían
un comercio muy muy grande er muy rico
muy variado que llegaba incluso a los
7.000 millones de dólares ese
intercambio y al verse interrumpido pues
por supuesto afectó de manera importante
a ambos países a sus economías y
principalmente a la zona fronteriza
donde hay un intercambio histórico muy
grande entre los dos países bueno los
gobiernos de estas naciones ya se están
acercando y han expresado su voluntad de
retomar el tráfico vehicular que
faltaría para lograrlo qué condiciones
se deben cumplir bueno yo creo que está
reanudación de las relaciones y
especialmente las relaciones económicas
y comerciales no van a ser tan rápidas
como mucha gente lo ha venido diciendo
no ha habido demasiado optimismo en este
sentido no
y digo esto porque creo que la economía
venezolana está muy muy deteriorada y no
creo que sea capaz en el corto ni
mediano plazo de estar preparada para un
comercio como el que hubo a comienzos de
este siglo sí creo que va a haber un
rebote importante en algunos sectores
por ejemplo en el tema agrícola de
productos agrícolas
y de alimentos donde colombia tiene una
gran ventaja competitiva respecto a
otros países para surtir a venezuela
debido a la cercanía que tiene con con
las principales ciudades vence las donde
un un camión con alimentos se puede
colocar en 20 horas o menos en cualquier
ciudad de venezuela entonces creo que
todo hace un proceso gradual que tiene
todavía que fortalecerse mucho la
economía venezolana sujeta todavía
sanciones internacionales y a una poca
digamos capacidad de reacción para poder
tener un comercio realmente grande por
lo menos esta situación creo que va
en el que en el corto y en el mediano
plazo va a subsistir y le pregunto qué
impacto tendrá esta decisión esta retoma
en el momento que se dé se espera un
fortalecimiento del comercio o volver a
los mismos niveles previos al cierre
es bueno si se llegara a los niveles
previos al cielo sería realmente un
fortalecimiento
importante e insisto que este va a ser
un proceso seguramente
muy muy muy gradual
tienen que volverse a
generar lazos a nivel consular a nivel
de comisiones fronterizas a nivel por
ejemplo fitosanitario temas de seguridad
temas de infraestructura también para
que el para que este comercio sea un
comercio o sea un comercio grande e
importante